[Music]
my name is Mike McDonald and I'm a
product manager on Google cloud platform
I've worked on firebase for about five
five and a half years I've been building
mobile apps for a long time and today
we're gonna go through a couple of the
kind of best practices that I've seen
that build secure apps and kind of
conversely I've seen a lot of insecure
apps right I've seen websites that I can
go to and download an entire database
just because they didn't follow a couple
really simple tips so first of all just
to level set how many people have used
firebase or how many believe heard of
firebase to start with great awesome how
many people have built an app and
shipped it on firebase okay about half
and room awesome so if anyone needs to
feel free to run out of the room and
just start screaming if you see
something that you're doing wrong and
then you know we can hopefully fix that
really quickly otherwise for the rest of
you hopefully it's not too repetitive
but we're gonna go into a lot of like
really in-depth examples of how to build
secure apps on firebase so hopefully
this isn't too old hat but if you wanted
to build a kind of traditional mobile or
web application you'd build something
like this so your mobile app or your
browser talks to a web server and that
web server is say running you know
Python and Django or maybe it's running
you know Ruby and rails things like that
and within that server you know not only
are you doing the the business logic of
what your application does but there are
a lot of ambient concerns that you have
to deal with you have to authenticate
your users you have to make sure they're
authorized to do what they're allowed to
do and maybe you have to validate schema
because you're writing to a database or
some other API and then you have to deal
with a bunch of other things of just
running and managing infrastructure so
you know doing OS or language runtime
updates unless you're using you know
some server less compute maybe you're
not doing that but the point is there's
a lot of stuff going on that is not
directly related to what your
application is doing and so that's the
whole premise of firebase right firebase
is eliminate that middle tier server and
let your applications talk directly to
manage infrastructure so let them talk
directly to a database or let them
upload a file directly to a cloud
storage bucket and that obviously
presents a lot of issues right like
unfair
did clients on the internet the Internet
is a very scary place if you haven't
already spent a lot of time there right
there are if you just look at web server
logs of a web server that you run say on
a GC instance you see IP addresses
coming from all over the world right
people are are doing malicious things on
the internet you want to put yourself
kind of ahead of the rest of the
Internet by doing a couple really little
things to really make yourself secure so
we're gonna go through those tips by
building an application right so we're
all at a conference I did not travel
very far I live in the Bay Area but I'm
sure many of you are here and you have
to expense things right so I don't know
how tedious of a process it is at your
companies but some companies you know
you have to like fax receipts in it's
terrible we want to build a better
expense reporting experience right so I
want to take a photo and have that photo
somehow magically become a number right
we can use fancy machine learning things
I've heard a lot about that um and we'll
actually use firebase to build this
experience I think we can do it really
really quickly so I have myself and the
first thing that I need to do when I'm
building an application and we're
talking kind of any any normal
application I need to do authenticate
myself I need to say hi I'm Mike and I
need some way of actually proving that
so I can get information about myself
and then I need to upload that photo and
so we're living in a firebase world I
can use cloud storage for firebase and
suck that photo right up off my device
and drop it in a cloud storage bucket
and then we can use the magic of cloud
functions so cloud functions are kind of
event-driven compute off of various
services so whenever an object is
dropped in my storage bucket I can
trigger a function and then I'm not a
super savvy developer I'm just gonna
call the cloud vision API I'm not gonna
write my own you know OCR or any of that
I'm just gonna let cloud vision OCR it
and my function will you know get the
the response look for the largest dollar
value on a receipt and then write that
information to cloud fire store and then
cloud fire store maybe we want to say
aggregate over you know the total sum of
my expenses that I can get that number
so maybe that'll trigger another cloud
function that cloud function will do a
sum right back to cloud fire store and
then notify me the user in real time of
hey you know you've uploaded this
expense your sum is now X
and normally you could build this app
where your file storage is public on the
internet and your database is readable
or writable by anyone and those are
obviously very bad things so let's walk
through how to not do that let's how to
kind of do that security as we're
building the application so my tips are
structured we're gonna talk about a tip
and then we're gonna talk about the
mitigation along the way so as I
mentioned the Internet is a very scary
place you should never trust things on
the client because your clients can look
something like this right if you've
built a web app on firebase
I'm sure you've copied and pasted this
config snippet a million times it
literally has an API key the location of
all of your resources etc and if you
leave your resources public on the
internet someone can do that and they
can just say oh I'm gonna just write to
your database anywhere so you really
can't trust the client to do anything
securely we've provided a number of
tools in firebase that help mitigate
these risks but I get this all the time
people are like oh my god this is scary
this is out in the world like yes and
it's by design and it's not a problem if
you follow the rest of the tool or the
tips in this presentation so the first
of those is right I just said trust
nothing but we have to trust something
right otherwise we can't really do
anything and so the way that we do that
is via firebase authentication and so
we're gonna go into a brief a little I
guess we're gonna explain how firebase
authentication works and why we can
trust it and kind of use that as the
root of trust for the rest of our
application so how many people have
signed in via Google I would assume
almost everyone in the room great if
anyone has looked at the information you
get back you get back information like a
user ID you get a profile picture URL
you get obviously your Google ID and you
can imagine a world where you want to
say talk to firestore and you just pass
along those claims you're like hey I'm
Mike you know and firestar is gonna be
like wait like anyone could say that
they're Mike right that that doesn't
make sense
and so identity providers have taken to
providing you an access token so if
you've ever done o auth programming or
similar you get this access token and
that's this kind of opaque string that
just represents you and we can actually
take that and firebase auth we've got to
pass that along and say hey
I've signed in via Google with this
access token and firebase off can say
hey Google like is this actually a valid
access token has Mike proven that that
he is who he claims to be and Google
will be like yep you know I can verify
that that access token is correct and
firebase off will say ok great
mike has signed in with firebase auth
let's actually give him a user ID in
firebase right because we can have
people sign in via Google or Facebook or
Twitter or a custom provider we kind of
need you know some standard that we can
all rely on within the firebase products
and so we'll give you a UID and that'll
also allows you to do things like you
know a user signs it anonymously and
then we can upgrade them as they sign in
and merge those accounts
we'll give them a user ID and we will
also say hey take this other
cryptographically signed token so if
folks are familiar with a JSON web token
we give you this JSON web token that
says information about that user so it
looks like this it's this long kind of
seemingly opaque string but it has three
important parts it has a header and that
basically says this is the algorithm
that was used to sign the token etc and
then this is the juicy part it has a
body with a bunch of data and that data
has all the same kind of provider
specific information so things like the
name the email the name of the
application used and then some other
custom claims like hey I signed in via
firebase here's my Google or I signed in
via via Google and firebase you know
here are my my various emails and then
it has and this is the most important
part it has a signature so there is no
prior knowledge of cryptography
necessary don't worry
but basically what what happens here is
Google has a public/private key pair so
one thing is secret your your private
key and then we offer a public key for
verification and firebase off will kind
of translate that Google credential into
a firebase off token that it signs with
its private key and so it basically
signs the the header and the data and
puts that in a signature and so if
someone comes along and they change you
know they intercept your token and they
try and change it that signature no
longer matches and right when fire store
or cloud storage or any of those Google
properties will try and understand that
token they'll say hey something
wrong the signature doesn't match and so
that is kind of where our root of trust
comes from right and it would be
obviously very bad if you know those
those private keys leaked and so we
rotate them and we do all those security
things so that you are not trying to
build your own identity provider
you know don't roll your own crypto
don't build your own identity providers
there are lots of people who have done
this so you know we have we have done
the mistakes so that you don't have to
and then we fix them along the way so
now when I want to go and query
firestore I can say hey here's my JSON
web token pass that along and then
firestore knows how to validate that and
pull a bunch of claims out of that so
there you go it can say awesome you're
Mike you're this user ID here all the
properties associated with you which
gets us to our next part right so we've
kind of we know who our users are and we
can very like we can verify and trust
that they argue they claim to be but
there are a couple of other steps right
we've done our authentication of just
yes you are who you claim to be
but now there's the authorization step
of can you do the thing that you're
asking to do and then because again we
don't provide you a server to do all
these things we have to say okay how do
you do schema validation so when you
upload a file it looks like a certain
way or how do you do business logic to
validate that someone isn't inputting
malicious data and that's where security
rules comes in so firebase security
rules kind of stand between you know
your client and the backend that you're
accessing to provide you those
additional features and it does so via
this thing called attribute based access
control so some of you have probably
heard of role based access control and
we'll talk about that a little later but
after you based access control is just
here are a bunch of properties so the
user ID you know the request that you're
making the resource that you're
accessing go and derive some decision
based on that so we'll walk through that
hopefully some of you has seen this
before but if you haven't not a big deal
we typically start by defining a service
we are writing rules on storage and then
we offer this kind of match construct
and so we say if anyone for instance has
used the restful api is for google cloud
storage storage google api is calm slash
b slash the name of the bucket slash o /
the path the object we're just doing the
same thing we're saying okay let's match
kind of
restful path or the resource that you
want to access that little squiggly
character is a wild card so in this case
we're gonna say hey you know match the
bucket in your project and similarly we
can say okay let's imagine that we're
naming our the images that we're
uploading to cloud storage for firebase
this users the name of your user ID
expenses and then your expense dot JPEG
or expense that PNG and then I can do
these allow constructs so I can say
allow a read or allow a write if some
condition is true and this is the
attribute based part that I was talking
about earlier because those attributes
could be if the user matches you know
the user ID that we're here or a you
know a number of other things so we'll
start with the first one and we'll say
only let a user read their expenses or
write their expenses so this request dot
off dot u ID we're basically pulling a
field out of the token and matching it
to a name of the file and then we can
make it a little more complicated right
we can say okay any user can read only
their documents or only their their
expenses but now we were going to
enforce a few more constraints on rights
because we don't want someone uploading
you know a five gigabyte you know tar
ball we want someone uploading a thing
that has to be an image less than a
megabyte and again we can pull in those
attributes and make decisions based on
that and then lastly we can enforce
certain pieces of business logic so
imagine you don't want to allow an
expense to be overwritten because maybe
someone you know is trying to to change
it to look differently after the fact
they photoshopped it to have a different
value and so we're gonna say we're gonna
require that they can't overwrite their
objects so if there's already an object
there we don't let them write it so
that's kind of a very simple example but
hopefully it shows you the power and
flexibility of these rules
okay so we've uploaded our file we've
done so because we authenticated we
wrote some rules to ensure that it's the
correct thing
now we trigger our function and so our
function could look something like this
if you've ever written cloud functions
for firebase you pull in you know this
firebase admin library
we'd also pull in a Google cloud client
library for vision right we're gonna
make one call out to the vision API to
OCR we are going to write a little bit
of code that says hey
the biggest number on the screen and
then we're going to write that out to
cloud firestorm and the one thing that I
really want to emphasize here is we're
actually running as an admin so this
function is kind of not running as an
end user it has a higher level of
privilege and it's actually running
using a service account right so we
signed in our users with firebase
authentication but all of our compute is
running as this kind of robot service
account user and that uses Google cloud
I am and so historically inside of all
of your functions all of those functions
run with the editor role we kind of have
one identity and they all get editor so
that means that you know if you screwed
up your programming and you know maybe
there are cases where you know someone
uploaded a source code file and your
function eval did potentially that
function could now create virtual
machines or you know you can't change I
am roles but it can build other
resources or do you know things that it
really shouldn't be doing right all our
function needs is this concept of least
privilege right it needs to read from
cloud you know read from cloud storage
to do a vision check and then write to
cloud fire store so we have this concept
of per function identities and what that
means is you can create a new service
account and have that be given just the
amount of privilege that it needs and
you can do that via custom roles and I
am or minting access tokens if you're
accessing say you know the Google Drive
or Google sheets api's so we'll walk
through that so I have a function it was
called you know OCR receipt because
that's what it does it OCR is a receipt
and I'm gonna create a new service
account to represent the identity of
that function and then I'm gonna create
a custom role and I'm gonna call that
role you know only the cloud vision and
fire store thing and I'm gonna pass it
to permissions and this is a little
counterintuitive vision actually needs
object get because we're pulling from
GCS and then the only permission that
needs to right to fire store is again
sort of confusingly datastore entities
create as a bit of legacy there but
we've now gone from editor where it
could do anything in our project you
know modulo a few things - exactly -
permissions and then we are going to
actually grant that new role to our
identity
and then we're going to redeploy our
function with that identity so now we've
again gone from this incredibly over
privileged role down to exactly the two
permissions that we need to read from
from vision and storage and then write
to firestorm and then one of my other
favorite things so vision you may have
noticed doesn't actually have a I am
role so it relies on hoth scopes and so
you need this scope for instance the the
cloud vision scope and so we'll give it
the cloud vision scope and it doesn't
fit on the screen but we'll give it the
cloud storage scope as well so it can go
in right there and we can use this cool
thing called the metadata service so the
metadata server
sorry metadata server not service um
basically is an HTTP server that kind of
looks like it lives on your compute
instances and what it will do is it will
fetch tokens for you so when you deploy
right like how many people and and be
totally frank with me like how many
people have uploaded a service account
to their compute just like or like
occasionally you upload it to github
because you screw up I've done it it's
terrible yeah I see a couple hands on
that yeah
that's not great development practice
right because maybe your private repo
becomes public or somehow those
credentials leak the point of the
metadata service is that you don't have
to ever deal with credentials you can
just say hey metadata service give me a
token and we refresh those tokens you
know every half hour an hour so you're
not touching credentials at all you can
just say this is my identity give me a
token for the identity and so that's
what we're doing here and we're actually
even saying give me a token that's
scoped only to you know the two or three
services that I need and I can make that
request get the token and then do my
calls and under the hood our client
libraries are doing this for you I just
wanted to be very explicit hey this is a
really cool functionality a piece of
functionality that we we've provided
actually just recently okay
so we've kind of gone through half of
our flow where we've been able to
securely upload a file and then run some
things as admin securely before writing
back to cloud fire store so the storage
rules that we wrote I would categorize
is pretty simplistic if you've ever
written cloud fire store rules they're a
little trickier so we're gonna go
through some similar concepts and then
see kind of how we extend that into the
future
so um as I mentioned and this is gonna
be kind of a slight point of difference
that right that we did from the function
happened as an administrator which means
that actually a bunch of these rules are
are not enforced right because we go
through I am and we do an iam check that
says hey your function is running kind
of as an administrator let's check there
this is mostly the the firebase rules
are mostly for your end-users and
they're kind of designed purposefully
for that but I'm going to go through an
exercise of we also want to ensure that
maybe you know there is a category of
user who is writing their expenses
directly to the database maybe we have a
mode in our app that you know you don't
have a receipt and you just have to put
in the amount manually we still want to
to provide for that so we would have to
kind of write that schema out in our
database and also it's just good
practice to see people you know walk
through this so we'll start off with
kind of a similar set of constructs that
we had earlier right you have a service
in this case it's fire store and you
have that kind of you know similar
boilerplate path of databases documents
etc for those of you who haven't used
fire store it's a document collection
database so you have collections for
instance expenses and then a document
named you know the expense ID so you
know expense JPEG or whatever and we're
gonna say we actually care a lot more
about schema validation so imagine we
kind of did you know the authentication
check and and we did a you know if the
user can can do whatever we want to
validate for instance that you know
unlike just the file name you know like
we have in storage maybe our documents
have to have certain properties so in
this case we're actually going to write
three properties the image URL so we
could pull down our file and display it
in the app the amount of money and then
the user ID of the user that actually
wrote it and so the first thing we did
was you basically said this document can
only have those properties that's what
that has only check is and the next
thing that we're gonna do is we're
actually in a type check those we're
gonna say okay the image has to be a
string the because it's just a URL out
to storage the amount has to be a number
and the UID also has to be a string it's
just a firebase off UID
so we've done just simple schema
validation but then we can do some more
complicated things we can say for
instance the image URL has to match a
certain regular expression so only allow
them to store images that are stored in
cloud storage for firebase or maybe we
don't allow receipt expenses over a
thousand dollars right we're like whoa
you shouldn't be doing that in our
mobile app so we're gonna limit that and
the last one that we want to do is kind
of that quick off check of the user
who's writing this document has to
actually be that user right I don't want
to impersonate you I don't want you
changing my document later etc and then
if we wanted to kind of for completeness
we could say things like allow update
allow delete etc if a rule is not
specified everything fails closed right
that's how this whole thing works so
don't worry you know your entire
database is not public on the internet
unless you do something like say allow
reads and writes everywhere which you
know that is an option when you start in
test mode you can say yes allow
everything to be public on the internet
because it's really fast to iterate not
great development practice and I'll get
into some ways that we can help kind of
make that easier in the future but
there's another tool right if you're
looking at that and you're going oh god
you know I have you know model classes
with fifteen or twenty different
properties and I'm storing them in
firestore this is gonna get crazy to do
that all manually do we have the tool
for you so I always feel kind of funny I
work at Google I've worked at Google for
a while um has anyone heard of protocol
buffers okay it's a Google conference I
guess it kind of makes sense so protocol
buffers are basically a way of defining
a schema independent of you know a
programming language so it's an
interface definition language so I can
define an expense proto and I can say
hey that has a string image URL an
amount of money and a UID those fields
are all required maybe actually you know
I should have made image URL optional
because you know maybe we have people
typing in expenses manually but you can
actually generate a bunch of things from
that for instance you can generate all
of your classes for your model objects
so for instance it would expend or it
would create expense Java and it would
create you know expense that Swift and
typescript and whatever other languages
and we've extended it to also create
rules to validate those model
Jax right so what happens here is your
flow is you define your objects and
protocol buffers and then it generates
the model objects on your client as well
as the rules on your server to validate
those model objects so if you're always
deploying those things in sync you
should never get to a point where things
are kind of egregiously broken in your
data model because you should never be
writing those things so definitely check
that out it's just kind of an open
source tool you can run it yourself and
it will generate all of the the various
you know model objects that you want as
well as rules to validate them and that
makes it a little easier right because
now you just say oh is this an expense
and pass it in and it's like yes or no
it's an expense you still have to to
include whatever kind of other business
logic checks you have we're actually you
know investigating imagine if we go back
and instead of just saying what they are
imagine if you could specify conditions
in a proto as well to say hey this value
has to be between you know zero and a
thousand dollars in ammount and then we
could kind of automatically do that as
well so there are some kind of
interesting ways for improvement the
other ones just kind of going out on a
limb is actually going in the reverse
and saying you have a Java class
generate me rules off the Java class to
validate it well that's a little bit of
a harder problem but still something
super interesting and if anyone is
looking for fun computer science
problems definitely you know build
something share it with us
we'd love to see it cool
so we talked through that example of you
know a user writing some more complex
data now we know that our users are
going to be reading from our our
information so we'll do a similar
exercise we'll say great you know users
can read all their own expenses everyone
should know what this looks like we're
just gonna say yep you know you can get
a single document or you can query for
all of your documents assuming that your
ID matches the ID in that document right
remember only created things we had to
ensure that those are matched we're
gonna do the same thing on queries and
so this would prevent me from querying
someone else's data which obviously we
don't want and that's where we get to
the first gotcha and this is why fire
sore is a little interesting right so
you can imagine that we have in our
expense expenses collection three
different expenses and maybe we have
more than that but we'll start with
three and there are two expenses by me
user one two three four five four ten
dollars and three
and then some other user has you know a
dollar-fifty expense so as you can see
that and then our other one is different
and so you might kind of natively expect
that hey um I have this set of rules
that saying you know only give me my
things I'm in a query and you know maybe
I'm gonna get only my documents and that
is not how things work right people get
really tripped up here because firestore
is like you know no I I can't feasibly
give you only those things right maybe
there are only three items but maybe
there are three million items and Fire
story's gonna look at every single
document and be like ah yes you know
Mike needs these three items so you may
kind of reformulate that and be like oh
you know I'm in development all the
documents are my own right I own every
single one of them and that's the only
thing in the database so you may do the
same thing you may say hey you know give
me all those documents they're all mine
right and nope firestore still can't do
that and again kind of what's happening
is we have to know kind of beforehand if
we can fulfill the request right so you
actually have to say hey write a query
that says give me all of the documents
where do the UID
is equal to you know I hard-coded one
two three four five but what I would do
is I would pull my UID
client-side off that token and then
match that and in that case fire sir is
basically asking this question right can
I prove that this operation will be
allowed without ever looking at the data
right because if we had to look at a
billion documents in order to return you
one document that would be an incredibly
incredibly slow database and an
incredibly slow product and that's not
the promise of you know firebase and
especially not cloud firestore where we
have to do you know tens or hundreds of
milliseconds of sync time and so the
answer in that case is yes we can
because you've provided information in
the query that we match with the rules
that you've written so that's the
concept that you kind of need to think
about when you're writing firestore
rules is we are validating it based on
the rule and the query not based on the
underlying data okay so I said that I'd
come back to this what about role based
access control right so we've been
living in a world with we'll go oh I
won't go all the way back but we've been
living in a world with a bunch of
different attribute checks
right of you know ensure that the size
is less than this and the UID matches
this but I think a lot of people
conceptually think about things in role
based access control terms right you're
like I'm a user you know maybe I have a
construction worker role therefore I can
access a tool box right like life just
sort of kind of works this way so Iraq
as opposed to a back user role resource
and maybe there are cases you know we've
gotten a little more fancy in our
application and you know we work for a
big enterprise and they have you know
admins who are checking our expenses and
we have to give the admins access to
view our expenses to audit or whatever
and so we can write this little you know
kind of local function and say you know
hey if it's me allow me to read it or if
this person accessing is an admin but
how do we get to that kind of is admin
check we can do that in a couple ways
but the simplest is you can actually
write this kind of little local function
is admin and what it's gonna do is it's
actually going to look up data that is
in the database
so you can create like access control
lists in your database or for instance
if you're building kind of like you know
sharing information if you're you know
building a Google Docs or Google Drive
clone you could say hey these are all
the people who have access to a document
in our case we're just gonna create you
know another collections called admins
and you know hey we're gonna look up and
say is this user in the admins
collection and if they're in the admins
collection great will allow them to be
an admin which of course brings this
amazing interesting question of like oh
well how does someone get in the admins
collection if you know if doing so now
grants them these these magical powers
the zeroth-order answer is the one that
I commonly do is literally just go into
the console and copy an ID and paste it
in but that's obviously not not super
scalable so let's imagine that we're
gonna actually use another another
function a piece of functionality of
firebase off and our integrations which
are called custom token claims so a
custom claim is something like we have
here of in is admin flag and if we go
all the way back to that first section
on firebase off we talked about that
token and we talked about the body and
within that body there are a bunch of
kind of normal claims like my email
and we can augment those with custom
claims so we could for instance when
that token is being created create it
with this additional flag that says you
know this person is an admin therefore
they can do another set of things so you
might be like oh man that's awesome you
know I can put all sorts of information
I can put you know the company that they
work at you can put you know group
information you can store profile photos
don't do that actually I had someone do
a 10 megabyte profile photo
turns out HTTP headers do not take well
to 10 megabyte photos in the header and
so we've kind of provided a couple of
limits on that right so custom claims
aren't kind of a panacea for all of your
authentication needs right we limit them
to a kilobyte so you can only kind of
put static data and like a small amounts
of static data and also we don't want
them to be heavily dynamic right these
things are refreshed
you know when the token gets refreshed
roughly once an hour
and so don't store information like the
chat rooms that a user is allowed to
access because they'll still be able to
access it for an hour right if you need
you know small dynamic pieces of data
store that in something like fire store
in another collection and do a lookup
like we had with exists to actually look
and see if that document exists -
shameless plugs so Jen person one of the
firebase das did a really good talk that
dives all the way into use cases around
custom claims when you should use them
and when you shouldn't and then if you
enjoyed the the kind of data modeling
perspective yours truly
gave a absolutely fantastic YouTube
video yeah not biased at all where we
dive into kind of more complex examples
and then we also solve that
bootstrapping problem of how does the
first user get into to a place so we've
written a bunch of code thus far and I
don't know about you I know when I when
I write my apps I don't always test them
so I'm not gonna ask people if they test
their apps but it's something that we
all know that we should do like brushing
our teeth and flossing and we're gonna
try and make it as easy as possible to
do those things right so there are a
couple ways that we provide to actually
test that functionality out right I
wrote a bunch of rules and you're like
great Mike those look fine but prove to
me that they're actually secure so
that's what we gonna do now so we
provide the first tool which is a
simulator and so a simulator is in our
console we allow you to write where you
edit those rules actually test that
those rules are doing what you think
they're doing so I've copied that exact
same set of rules over on the left side
of the screen you can see hey we're
gonna try a create and we can create a
document so my I actually went to the
taco trucks across the street and so you
know I don't have an expense for it but
imagine that cost me 10 dollars and I
took a photo of it so the photo is throw
it over in storage ten dollars my UID
remember that number one two three four
five great I'm gonna build that document
I'm gonna go down to the authentication
section and I'm gonna put my UID in
there one two three four five and then I
might click run and run it's gonna say
yup you know your read or your create
two expenses slash lunch has all those
keys matches you know is less than
$1,000 etc but if for instance I just
changed that firebase UI D 2 1 3 5 7 9
so basically not myself but I'm trying
to you know to write a document that has
that it's gonna fail that right and
that's obviously by design and the same
would happen if I say you know change
the expense to $2,000 or similar it
would kind of give me that nice failure
message of hey something's wrong so it's
a really nice way of doing that if I
drop the simulator down it'll also
provide a total version history right so
every time I save and redeploy those
rules I'll have a version history so I
can kind of test that as I want and then
if something broke I could for instance
kind of you know one click rollback in
the simulator hey get back to a safe
state but obviously you know that's kind
of nice for these one-off things but
ideally you know when you're developing
you have a little bit you know you have
unit tests or an integration test so we
also provide a local emulator and so the
local emulator will basically allow you
to programmatically do those similar
tests so you'd have your rules and you
have kind of your local database you can
read and write to it and I can create
you know hey in my expenses collection
maybe I want to go and fetch your
expense versus my expense and I've
written rules that they kind of do
and then I can write assertions and say
hey this test should fail under this set
of circumstances but you know maybe this
test should succeed and then I can
validate those so that's a really nice
way of again getting more towards the
automation of your security awesome so
we've talked a lot about kind of the
deep technical aspects of how to secure
your application but there are a lot of
things that actually I think are more
common and more frequently done
incorrectly there are much bigger
security vulnerabilities so I'm doing
another talk tomorrow
shameless plug number three I guess that
goes really in-depth on kind of threat
models and threat environments but
basically the idea is there are threats
in the world everything from you know
the random people on the internet
pinging your website to you know state
sponsored entities who are you know
doing very targeted and specific attacks
and so in the category of threats right
when you build an application you want
to kind of pick the threats that are
most likely because those are obviously
they're more likely to occur therefore
you should kind of try and solve them
initially unless you know again it
depends on what you're doing but
generally understanding kind of the you
know what threats are out there what
tools may be used to to you know break
your application or have malicious
things and one of the the most common
ones and I think we call it you know
sort of insider risk or you know
unintentionally malicious behavior is
you know everyone is really worried
about this guy right you know the hacker
who's sitting around trying to break
into your app but like practically
speaking it's like this guy you know
from IT who like accidentally deleted
everything like that's a much bigger
threat than you know this thing right
like much lower probability may be you
know a little more dangerous but
practically speaking if this is gonna
happen 98% of the time because they
click the wrong button that is still a
really big threat that you want to deal
with so this Mike at McDonald's calm guy
we don't know if we can trust him I
wanted to add him to my project and and
typically you know my my other you know
my alter-ego is an editor right or is an
owner I can do anything in this project
but maybe I like don't really trust this
this other one um and so I want to give
him kind of more you know specific
permissions I don't want to give him
full access to say all of my business
data or you know access to send push
notifications I want to say hey Mike you
know I'm gonna give you a particular
role and we can actually go and say okay
you know there are some analytics roles
that are you know reader or writer
there's maybe a develop role and you
know Mike is gonna be doing some
development work for me so I'll give him
the developer admin role so you know he
can go and delete the entire database
but he can't send push notifications to
spam all of my users right so there's
you know some guide rails there and if
you need you can kind of bump out of
that into Google cloud platform and use
the custom roles in Google cloud
platform to create similar to what we
did for I am example give you know my
cat McDonald comm only access to a
database and maybe even you know only
read access to a database and write
access the storage you can kind of
create whatever you want and give them
that customer ole and the firebase
console will respect that cool and the
last one again kind of going a little
more abstract but developer experience
is a really really important part of
security right because if your processes
are really cumbersome right if you you
know have a bunch of manual steps people
are gonna kind of bypass them or you
know take shortcuts and end up in places
where you've kind of unintentionally
built vulnerabilities into your
application and there are a couple
common ones that we see really really
often shared environments is a huge one
right so for those of you who are
running firebase apps today you may have
things like you know your dev and your
beta and your prod apps all in the same
project and that means they're sharing
an off database that means they're
sharing an actual database you know that
means your metrics are kind of looking
interesting projects are kind of a nice
firewall between those right because you
want an entirely separate database that
you know if someone comes along and
accidentally deletes it that's fine
right it was staging you can rebuild it
and so really really recommend that and
I think there are there are a lot of
people who say oh man it's really hard
to set up environments because it
requires a lot of manual toil of you
know enabling all of your your API is
etc
so tools like terraform or you know
deployment manager will help you kind of
build that infrastructure so the
infrastructure is a code a type thing
will help you do that
easier and related to that right like if
you have a very manual tool chain a lot
of times you know people will do things
like you know they have for building an
iOS app have like the one Mac Mini in
the corner of the office really like
build the app on and then you know put a
thumb drive in and take the IPA file off
and walk it over to another computer to
upload it to iTunes Connect like that's
a really bad experience and you're
likely to you know copy the wrong file
or do something like that and so CI or
CD tools so using cloud build or we have
a really great mobile tool called
Fastlane which does things like automate
you know provisioning profile signing
and upload to the App Store and kind of
doing that you know securely so not
everyone at your company can say upload
an apk to the App Store only you know
the cloud build deployment agent can do
that you can kind of build some some
additional security in there okay so
that is all I have I have about ten
minutes if you have questions I am happy
to answer them I and I will stick around
after as well otherwise please submit
your feedback and if you have other
questions i'm on twitter at ascii mike
ASCI IMI ke and would love to help you
wherever you are in your development
journey also if you built awesome
firebase apps send them my way send them
to you know firebase on twitter right
into support again I love seeing what
you build and I may try and break it and
give you feedback on that so thank you
all very much for coming and enjoy the
rest of next
[Music]